hey all attention cashier and that's how
you choose a video we're actually not
gonna be looking at this week's data set
which is on astronauts instead I was
actually reading a text book this
weekend and it was the interpretive
machine warning a guy for making plaque
box models explainable and I'll put the
link in the description below but
basically the main idea behind this
entire textbook was described methods on
how to create some inferences of why
your models are predicting these actual
predictions um and that's kind of the
big problem with these black box models
although you have a lot of predictive
power
you're also sacrificing interpretability
whereas with logistic regression when
you're Russian and all other generalized
when you're models your basic sacrifice
acridity to power for better interpret
ability so in this text with a to show
you kind of ways to still use these
models with high predictive power but
also be able to increase the interpreter
ability by it so we're just gonna do
that I'm gonna load up a our markdown
file
let's oops our markdown and we're gonna
call this um tidy Tuesday black box
models okay so I'm going to delete this
garbage and we're gonna load in the tidy
verse tidy models the aims housing the
broom package and then we're gonna load
in the IML package so the tidy verse is
going to be for data manipulation our
tidy miles is how we're gonna make the
actual models our Eames housing package
is going to supply the data that broom
package we'll also do some of the data
manipulation specifically for cleaning
up our models and the IML will really
show we'll be the kind of the main
package where we're gonna be doing the
interpretation of these black box models
so with aims housing we can actually
just say we'll call its aims DF and
we'll say make aims and then we can just
do a basic look at it
and it's the thing that we have it says
the we've used this data set before if
we do a glimpse on it we can see that
there's 81 columns with three five three
thousand rows what I'm actually gonna do
is I'm gonna select select only the
numeric ones just so we can do better
interpretations of the values you select
so I do a select if is that numeric
select is that select if what is that
numeric okay
additionally um with aims housing data
set you're gonna have to select the was
a sale sale price and then I'm gonna say
everything just so it's a little bit
cleaner so we have the first column as a
variable at which I predict okay so
we're gonna do that and I'm gonna assign
that to a to itself stub to the MCF okay
so when we look at the actual thing the
actual textbook one of the main ideas
behind it is just kind of using linear
models to describe your data so let's
first just make a baseline linear model
or we're gonna predict the this sale
price using all our predictors so so
that's it you know pretty quick takes
about two seconds to make linear model
to predict sale price if we do a tidy
function so if say linear model tidy we
can kind of get our terms our estimates
for the coefficient standard error
p-values you know the generic when your
model stuff and so when we use the
linear model I'm trying to interpret it
a common plot that we use is called like
a coefficient plot so if we just say
like x equals term michaelis estimate
plus geo I'm like column and we just
maybe do a chord what oh gee Emma was at
gym wait um oops let me just do a filter
so I'll say uh or maybe we can do a
slice minus one
yep so we
intercept and we can see how we can look
at our estimate yada-yada addition we
can also say was it comp dot int equals
true I think yeah so if we do that and
then we do so if you do comp that in we
get our comp high and low so instead of
doing GM we can also do our GM was it
point point range a sy n equals what
it's up y min equals comp top
well why max equals conf hi and then we
can kind of get some comps intervals
with our estimates but there's a huge
problem with this actual plot so
although we're seeing our coefficients
so in in a in a visual manner so if we
actually just do the the table you know
here's our coefficients you know doesn't
do crazy well if you look at our
coefficients we can see that actually
when we do another thing look plus scale
what X log 10 or scale y log 10 we can
see our coefficients it's not really a
great introduction of how we should be
looking at it because it will get your
sold was here so your soul may have a
kazeer owe or if we look at say a lot
area lot area has like a coefficient of
like 0.9 right so if we can we just do
that so if we go to a claw area is 0.3
compared a lot frontage which is eight
eighty seven point three seven five so
um
every night we looked at the these
coefficients we would say okay um let me
year your remodel add in a lot frontage
those are the biggest things that we
need to look at or basement finished in
whatever area one that's our best
coefficient but they're on different
scales so for example on watt frontage
or a lot area has a small coefficient
but the area is probably on a much
larger range right well or just a larger
scale
prepare to say your remodelled added
right so you might have a lot area like
300 or 3000 but it's it's really rare to
have a year remodel added to be like you
know 3000 - so this is a coefficient
plot but what we want to do is actually
basically multiply our values for each
term times its estimate and then we'll
get it's actually contribution to our
sale price and what that is called is an
effects plot so let's say create an
effect plot so if we raise take for
every term we're multiplying each sample
by its estimate for each term okay so
really calculating each marginal effect
for each estimate okay so let's do that
and that's why we're actually to use the
the tidy function so if we do a tidy we
have our terms um we don't really need
our our intercept because every term
will receive that same intercept it's
essentially the average so what we're
gonna do is we want to say select a term
and estimate okay and we go to our game
data what we can do is just do a beauty
and we'll say primary key is equal to
row number because each each row is a
house or a sample and then we can do a
gather as a key equals key value equals
value and - I guess we don't really need
sale price but we'll say - you know just
that it's the only thing and then we
always say - sale price okay so here's
our oops
- sale price and then we'll say - PK
right and then what we can do is we can
do a left join so we're essentially
saying we're going to join by the key so
that way we'll have our coefficient for
all these samples okay let's love join
this oops I'll clean this up a little
bit so
and we'll say I equals C and we'll say
was it key equals term like let's see oh
okay so what we can see here is like
here's though here's our our first
sample it's corresponding feature its
value and and then the actual
coefficient for it so what we're gonna
do is mutate and say we'll say effect is
equal to value times estimate cool and a
space see it so now we can just do a GG
plot x equals key y equals effect and
then we can do like a box plot and then
we'll say plus a cork foot okay so one
other thing that we should do is
probably probably scale it so one thing
I want to do is I go a log 10 scale I
logged a log 10 transformation however
we have negative values for the negative
coefficient so well I I'm gonna actually
do is I'm gonna make sure do this so
I'll say um I'll create a pause neg
value so it'll be an if-else effect is
also equal to 0 then I'll be a negative
and then it we pause positive and then
I'll change the effect to the absolute
value okay and now I can just say color
equals pause Ned cool and then I'll do a
plus scale Y scale X log 10 skill plus
kill scale Y log 10 and there we can see
we can see how our plot is a little bit
different compared to our effects plot
so if we look at our effects plot we can
see it's all scattered in reality for
here we can see that the thing that adds
the most contribution is actually
longitude and latitude for a positive
for a to increase or sale price in your
your your house if we look at the
negatives we can see open porch so those
have the negative contribution towards
them okay so that's just kind of a quick
way to view the actual effects of the
plot so let me say create an effect plot
well so now that we're actually showed
like just kind of how you interpret some
linear models or how to make some pasta
to analyze your models I'm not going to
start making some um some black box
models so I'll say this like start
making some non interpret table models
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
create just the baseline for a random
forest model so I'll be a ran forest set
mode two regression and I'll set the
engine to was it random forest and I'll
create also do a XE boost model because
these are these are kind of the models
that most people would view as like non
interpretive miles that are also very
popular so I'll set the engine to was it
actually boost actually set boost trees
up set engine there you go so have these
models that are just on here but what
I'm going to do is I'm just gonna train
the models or train and create train
models I'm actually not going to do any
tuning for it I'm gonna use the the
baseline parameters so I'm going to say
to set that seed 42 and all just say
random forest model right in forest
panel and I'll say how was it fit and
then say sill price data equals was it
game dia and I'll say actually be model
is equal to the actually be model it'll
fit it just to its values fit it to the
data so it's sale price data equals
Eames
yeah and when I do this it's actually
just gonna run it with the default
parameters starett's so there's some
default parameters for random forests
xgb
that though just can't use as like basic
you know basic starting points so I'm
gonna start training these models okay I
think I actually created them right okay
we got that shimano cool so we trained
these models it was pretty fast because
we weren't doing any cross-validation um
I would definitely say that your we're
already I might have over fit or under
fit of the model but this isn't really
about how how to optimize your model
parameters it's more about how to use
and interpret these black box models so
with the IML package um this is the
package that may basically uh show us
how to interpret these black box deep
warning models one of the main things is
like feature importance so what we can
do first is we have to kind of give it
the actual model data so I'm just gonna
do that so select and then say - sale
price and then it takes it as a data
frame so we have our X data and now we
can create our actual models that it can
I'm kind of like test on it so we're
gonna create two different models one
for our first random forest model so we
call it our F predictor and then you
give it the predictor and then yet say
you know the dollar sign our new give it
the actual model I'll give it the data
that the model data which is X data and
then we'll give it what we're actually
trying to predict which is sale price
okay and then we do a studio do the same
thing for the other other model so
actually be predictor predictor new and
then was it actually be model data
equals X data and y equals Eames the
sale price cool so let's just do a
feature importance plot so I'm gonna
just say RF feature
him and we'll say feature him new and
then we give it the RF predictor and we
can give it a loss function so see how
each predictor impacts a specific loss
and when I'm trying to communicate how
models model performance it's best to
communicate in the most simple or
simplest metrics when doing
presentations so I like to train models
to optimize off of root mean squared
error however it's not very it's pretty
hard to wrap your head around the root
mean squared error when computing like
average loss so I think the best metric
when computing when communicating
towards other people is mean absolute
error because you can essentially say
that
okay our model on average when it
predicts it's wrong why this much right
so on average each time it predicts the
sale price the sale price is off about
$200 instead of saying root mean squared
error which is like the square and then
square root of it it's very confusing
and it's not a good way to really
communicate to people I'm also gonna
build it with the the xgb
boost model so one of the big things
with these I would interpretability
things is it does take a little decent
amount of time to run it so I'm gonna
let that go and if we're actually going
to go over feature importance so most
most model Diagnostics are modeling
libraries will always kind of have it
feature importance and this essentially
shows
what features when it removes has most
impact on performance so in this case or
when we were looking at this we're
saying like okay so forth all of the
aims data so for all of these features
um if I remove your sold how does that
impact the mean absolute error okay so
what we can do now is we can do the RF
feature in and then I think we just plot
it and we see right here so it's saying
that when it removes gr live area which
I think it's a great living area maybe
or
like that we can see that it has a huge
loss in predictive power we can all see
your bill is a huge indicator of the
sale price or total basement purse of
square foot for its 4 square foot these
all make a lot of sense for how it's
looking at what's making predictions on
sale price we can also look at the
actually boost feature importance just
actually want to do it separately so
what we're actually expect expect more
interpreting these two models is we kind
of want the main feature importance to
be the same if we're kind of looking at
robust models however if your ensemble
models or doing some stacked model
framework it's actually got a good to
have models who have different future
importances that's probably for another
video so when we look at these two
models we can see that both extra boost
and random forests put a huge emphasis
on random forests on a great living area
additionally they have total basement on
square foot and you're built on the top
three they're interchangeable you swap
them around but it still shows that the
main three features that they use for
evaluating sale price is the living area
you're built and twelve basement for a
square foot cool so that's a that's a
pretty simple plot but it's really it's
not really a thing that goes too deep
into the actual understanding of how
models work so another good thing that
that are the IML package comes with is
the feature effect function which plots
out the a le
and a le plot which the le plot let me
look
it's the UM it's kind of a weird word
it's here it's called the accumulated
local effects plot and it basically
tries to find how the features influence
on average and one of the main things
that differentiates this pot with a
bunch of other plots so another plot
that you would probably think here of is
the partial dependence plot the part of
the Pens plots has a main
um has a main assumption where it
assumes that features are uncorrelated
oops
you saw my my thing are uncorrelated an
independent which is actually really bad
for most models so one of the main
reasons why people do black box models
is that they can use highly correlated
features or not or not independent or I
mean not independent or dependent
features so what does this really mean
it basically means that if you're using
a PDP plot on our features right now
which we know that if I just do a basic
correlation analysis so mzf core and
then just do it was a core we can see
that it's definitely has some correlated
features so for example one of the
things that's a good example of
correlate features is like height and
weight so the higher the the taller you
are the more you're gonna weigh since a
PDP plot would assume that's
uncorrelated it'll basically try to test
all his features in the feature space
what that means is a basis show or a
basic plot out on samples where a person
is like two foot tall but weighs 300
pounds which is unrealistic to see in
the wild which is why people use the a
le plot now or a community local effect
spots and basically a rule of thumb when
I was reading the textbook is you should
basically always use the le plot on
before PDP plots so that's why we're
gonna do the a le plot I'm also not
going to go into the math of it because
I don't think this is really out of the
scope of the video and I think the le
plot should just kind of it's more fun
to just kind of interpret the aole plots
so that's what we're gonna do I'm gonna
do our F le and say feature effects and
then we'll say new and we'll say our F
predictor you can also change it to our
feature effect and then you can specify
the predictor but in this case I want to
kind of look at all every feature and
its impact when predicting
we're also gonna do the xeb le sol
feature effects new and then actually be
a predictor Oh see so it says feature is
missing P as I said feature effect and
save feature effects cool I might take a
sip okay and what's cool again with the
IML package is you can just plot it out
for that okay so it's not looking good
so I'll do fig dot height equals 15 fig
dot width equals 15 just to make a
little bit larger I'm also gonna copy
this code chunk I pasted it right there
and then just the actually be a li so
that way we'll plot both and all while
this actually be spot is plotting out
we'll be looking at a random forest plot
okay cool
so what this plot shows is basically the
distribution of each marginal effect I'm
not you tomorrow for each average effect
from each feature okay which is pretty
useful okay so the y-axis is saying like
how are you predicting sale price and we
can see how we can see how okay when we
increase our law area from from like
twenty to a hundred we see we have a
huge increase in sale price but then the
actual rate of increase in sale price
starts to diminish however we can still
increase as it goes there's no actual
like was it a hump shaped distribution
of it see again with a gr olive area we
can see how a Jarl of area is just has a
high slope in general additionally we
will get the x-axis you can see how
those darker lines these are called our
rug rug mappings wherever and shows that
the density of most of our samples so
most of our samples and the lot frontage
are in like the 0 to 100 range and you
see our your built most of these how's
our basic newer houses are made after
the 40s or 1900s
so this is probably one of my favorite
pause when I'm trying to interpret these
machine learning models this shows like
each features effects you know kind of
like the simple curve of it
he is really hard to actually visualize
like three-dimensional effects instead
they just kind of show these like
faceted plots of each marginal effect on
on average for the distribution and we
also look at the bottom they actually
actually please panel and see it's kind
of showing the same thing we see at the
gr olive area has a huge a steep slope
and it's good so when we're actually
showing these models then um a lot of
these to all times you might get
questions on saying okay we have these
models we know how is how is reacting to
this entire dataset we know why it's
looking at this data and why it's kind
of making these predictions but one of
these things that you kind of need to
know is how can we how can like when you
when you're mala does a prediction we
kind of want to see like okay what
things we do we need a change to change
the prediction for example in the book
that they used in the book they're
talking about credit card applications
so but we have a machine learning model
that basically looks at like your your
payment history your gender your age and
they get rejected for a credit card they
probably want to know why
what contributing factors affected
contributed to them failing their credit
card application which that involves the
my model which is like local was only
let me look up the name of it it's a was
I took all the local surrogate models
and it's probably one of the most
popular um oops probably one of the most
popular models that they use for
interpretive modeling it's mostly just
for analyzing individual predictions so
it's like for analyzing how models make
individual predictions
I'll get cool and what's kind of funny
there's so much research about line
models or local surrogate models however
do actually implementing the line model
is pretty easy so I'll minced it to RF
lime and we'll say local model new and
an RF predictor but we have to give it
our X interest which is the sample that
we kind of want to look at so we'll just
say X data the first first was it the
first data point okay if we actually
plot the RF line we can see a we can see
how what the model was looking at so it
says the main reason why it made the
prediction of 20 was of $200,000 was
because of your G arrow living area
which had the most which had the largest
effect to your contribution of a home
sale price additionally they said that
since you had a two-car garage that had
a ten thousand dollar contribution to it
additionally their total basement or
square foot was a thousand eighty on
total square foot and then we can also
look at it for the the extra boost model
- so would say F JBL I'm a local model
new actually be predictor and then X dot
interest X was X data one okay
and then we can pop that out and let's
see how it what I was looking at
so again when I was looking at so this
is with the same the same house and I
basically used the same predictions and
it shows the same contribution of
effects in this case the actually boost
model actually puts a less effect on the
gr olive area additionally it has a
larger increase in their garage cars or
the the two two-car garage so that's
basically it for this video I wanted to
make a shorter one because I just read
this textbook and I thought was a pretty
interesting read and I think all this
stuff is pretty simple to implement and
you can kind of go to town and go crazy
with it
I think in the future I might implement
a lime model in some type of text
generation or text NLP model and put
that in a dashboard but I'll probably
for future videos so yeah that's it and
I'll see you next week and Teddy on